happy birthday Chicago I love you so
much I can't believe you're five years
old Kim Kardashian goes all out with a
Hello Kitty themed bash for her daughter
Chicago's fifth birthday and the whole
thing was perfect
get it Hello Kitty perfect I don't know
what's gonna top that anyway
this game's founder shared snaps from
the big celebration on social media
Sunday how cute is Shy's
Hello Kitty party
um so cute
got a little rained in so did it inside
these balloons are amazing
okay pause zoom in that's a Hello Kitty
slide and ball pit indoors
Okay carry on Kim please
[Music]
yeah Hello Kitty herself was at the bash
and danced with the birthday girl guests
Chow Down on waffle sticks fruit kebabs
and Hello Kitty grilled cheeses
naturally the cheese was pink because
duh and get this Kim arranged for a
ramen bar where guests could customize
their orders it's really fun to see the
lavish Soiree included a slime making
station face painting and a table for
painting ceramic Hello Kitties and in
true Kardashian fashion lots and lots
and lots of balloons I love that to
quote Kim the whole thing was he cute
how cute
[Music]
are these balloon trees
so cute guys
she even turned the floor of her house
pink for the event why not and if all
that wasn't sweet enough Shai blew out
the candles on a giant Hello Kitty cake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yay safe to say Kim is one sweet Mom
thank you Kim and Kanye West finalized
their divorce back in November and at
the time A source told E.T the reality
star is focusing on her kids my house is
so full but in the best way it's
amazingly full the former couple shares
four children together nine-year-old
daughter North seven-year-old son Saint
five-year-old daughter Chicago and
three-year-old son song but before Kim
through Shai's Hello Kitty Extravaganza
she was on Tooth Fairy duty after Saint
lost a bottom tooth it's my little
sister's birthday oh let me see this
lost tooth let me see this last tooth
and she's been teaming up with northie
for some epic content on their joint
Tick Tock account
foreign
[Music]
so whether she's throwing epic birthday
parties playing tooth fairy or engaging
in the latest Tick Tock Trends with her
little ones I am positive that Kim can
do kitty much anything
[Music]
thank you